add add and state the sum in simplest
form so what we have here we need to add
these two rational expressions or we
could view them as two adding two
fractions and whenever you add two
fractions you have to make sure that you
have the same denominator and clearly we
don't have the same denominator here so
we have to find a common denominator and
just like what you would do with regular
fractions for rational expressions like
this the common denominator is going to
be the least common multiple of these
two dots of these two denominators right
over here and to figure out the least
common multiple we just have to factor
each of these and then just make sure
that we have something that contains all
of the factors of each of these so if
you factor this so if we do a prime
factorization for the numbers and then
we factor the variables down to their
basic building blocks you get this as
being equal to four is the same thing as
two times two x to the third is x times
x times X and then Y is times y so
that's four X to the 3rd Y and then six
Y is the same thing as 2 times 3 2 times
3 times y so this is the prime
factorization of 6 oh well at least of 6
times just Y just you can't really
factor Y any more any any simpler than
that and so the the the common
denominator we can have for this is
something that has all of these factors
so let me draw it so this is going to be
equal to I'm going to rewrite this
fraction without this these these
rational expressions what I'm going to
rewrite them with a common denominator
so the common denominator we have to
have at least two twos in it if we have
any chance of being divisible by 4 so we
have to have 2 times 2 in it we have to
have 3 X's in it at least three X's in
it so times 3 x times X times X so we
have to have at least 3 X's in it and we
have to have at least one y in it so
this right here is just divisible by 4 X
to the 3rd Y in fact I just rewrote the
whole thing now we also want this common
denominator to be divisible by 6 Y or we
want it to be divisible by 2 times 3
times y so it has to have at least one 2
in it well lucky for us we already have
at least one 2 there
it has to have at least 1/3 in it we
don't have at least 1/3 here so let's
put a three in it and it has to have at
least one y over here and we already
have a y over here so we don't have to
add one so our least common multiple
over here is 3 times 2 times 2 times X
times X times X times y or another way
of thinking about it let me delete let
me so this right here this right here is
our least common multiple of 4 X to the
3rd Y and 6 Y and if we were to multiply
this out 3 times 2 times 2 that's the
same thing as 12 12 and then you have X
to the 3rd 12 X to the 3rd and over time
you can learn to do this in your head
I'm just really showing you every single
step that you could do 12 X to the 3rd
times y 12 12 X to the 3rd times y is
the common denominator so we can rewrite
this as 12 X to the 3rd Y plus something
over 12 X to the 3rd Y so to go from 4 X
to the 3rd Y to 12 X to the 3rd Y what
do we have to do well we're multiplying
it by 3 we're multiplying this
denominator by 3 if we multiply the
denominator by 3 we get 12x to the 3rd Y
which is the least common multiple but
if we multiply the denominator by 3 we
also have to multiply the numerator by 3
and so you multiply the numerator by 3
you get 3x plus 27 so you get 3x plus 27
up here and to go from 6 Y to 12 X to
the third plus 2 12 X to the third Y you
have to multiply it by 2 to make the 6
into or to gemalto you might have to
melt you have to multiply the 6 by 2 to
get a 12 you have to stick an X to the
third there because there's no X to the
3rd yet in the denominator and you
already have the Y so if you were to
multiply 6 Y by 2 X to the 3rd you'll
get 12x to the 3rd Y well if you do the
denominator by 2 X to the 3rd you also
have to multiply the numerator by 2 X to
the 3rd and if you multiply this out 2
times 7 is 14 and then you have 14 X to
the 3rd power and now we can add we have
the same denominator
so we have the same denominator here we
have 12 X to the 3rd Y and now we can
add the numerators so I'll start with
the highest degree term we have a 14 X
to the 3rd I can just we don't have any
other X to the third term so nothing to
add it to so we have 14 X to the third
and then the next lower degree would
have we have no x squared term we have a
3x right over here so then we have a 3x
I will do it in magenta so then you have
plus 3x and then you have plus 27 plus
27 and we're done there's no real
obvious simplification you can do not
everything up here is divisible by 2 or
this is writable by 2 but these aren't
these are divisible by 3 this one isn't
and so there's not a lot that you can
factor out of this they're not all
divisible by X and it looks like we are
done this is our sum in simplest form